the business model in traditional
business model that supported newspaper
newsrooms of the sort that I spent 20
years in is under extraordinary pressure
you have two things going on
simultaneously right now one is a
cyclical downturn of a pretty severe
kind but familiar sort of recession or
recession like decline in economic
activity plus inflation in newsprint and
other costs so you've got a really bad
sort of cycle and then on top of that
temporary cyclical problem you've got a
huge secular shift in advertising and
readership away from print and I don't
think the newspaper newsrooms that we've
known are likely to come through this
combination of pressures without in most
cases radical reductions in size to the
point where the mission of Civil Service
journalism that they were able to
support before including independent
foreign correspondents independent
investigative reporting of a reasonably
robust kind watchdog reporting at the
local national level it's going to be
very difficult to do that work in those
companies so then the challenge facing
journalism is how do you keep that work
alive and how do you keep the values
that made that work successful you know
alive and I think that that's a
challenge in part for philanthropy
that's why you know I'm interested in in
at the New America Foundation and
working with different models to try to
make that happen and I think it's a
challenge for publishers in the new
media to determine along with everything
else they learn about how to create
business models to do as the families
that own the great newspapers did in
once you find a successful business
model as a publisher what beyond making
money do you intend to do in this
constitutional system and I hope that a
new generation of publishers will answer
that call
in ways that the owners of newspapers
did before them but haven't so far
generally I loved being a foreign
correspondent I traveled in lots of
places and had lots of experience in war
zones in Sri Lanka and Kashmir in India
and Afghanistan you tend to think of the
of the travel and the landscapes that
you were in very privileged to be there
with a notebook in your back pocket and
just astonished from hour to hour of
what you were in the middle of but I
think most of what I love doing is
discovering things as a reporter and the
I the bin Laden's last project really
was a return to the basic kind of Street
reporting and courthouse reporting and
door knocking and sort of three yards in
a cloud of dust just fighting forward
against a target that really is a hard
target and and and but just the
adventure of discovering undiscovered
information is really what I what I most
enjoy